it's a busy road and it's about to be a
wider road county crews starting the
widening project on fort apache south of
warm springs joe mueller is live near
that intersection with just how this
will impact your commute joe
garrison well if you drive around this
area especially south of here towards
mountains edge it's it's it's easy to
spot all the new neighborhoods and the
new developments well with all this
growth means they need bigger roads and
people who live in this area are happy
to know that fort apache is finally
being widened
it's not safe
it's not lit
it'll just be so much
better and safer joe garcia lives in
rhodes ranch he knows that ford apache
needs some attention the improvement
is worth the wait this is footage from
our aviator drone of fort apache now
through summer the busy road between
warm springs and huntington cove will be
a construction zone we know the
southwest valley is growing faster than
any part of town right now county
commissioner justin jones says 17 000
drivers take this street daily if you've
ever driven on this part of fort apache
you know it's a mess there's only one
lane in each direction there's no bike
lanes there's no sidewalks it will soon
go from two lanes to four and have bike
lanes jones knows it will create
headaches it's going to be a great
project when it gets done but not going
to pretend that it's not going to be
painful for the next several months as
the more than 6 million project gets
done jones suggests alternate routes
like durango you've got work being done
in durango well i'll go down to buffalo
you go down to buffalo they're working
in buffalo garcia says all this work
needs to be done but it'll be worth it
now back out here live when this part is
done to huntington cove they will then
start the next phase which is south of
that two blue diamonds reporting live in
the southwest valley this evening joe
mohler live local now